[Music]
Raider running back hall-of-famer
also with the Chiefs a USC Trojan and
good see again we always notice people's
shoes when they come on for some reason
and my guys notice the issues you had on
you looking clean today yeah yeah so you
got your Raider color on yeah black on
Thursday night what color did they wear
I think the world or white did they yeah
I thought they were I guess what they
all black uniforms would look like on
Thursday night so I thought they did
white on white with silver yes yeah they
should try black on black now so well if
they moved to Vegas then they could do
black on black it looks it appears
though it they're they're leaning that
way do you like that possibility well
I'd like for teams to remain where they
are two teams in particular I grew up in
San Diego guys born and raised I went to
balboa stadium to watch my first game
that was before san diego stadium that
was before Jack Murphy I was before
Qualcomm I played in a halftime of a
charger game when I think it was John
Hado and those guys know ants all were
playing back back in those days and my
dad worked on the stadium so I got fond
memories and I always thought that the
charges would always be a part of the
fabric of San Diego were you a Chargers
fan oh yeah like I said Lance Alworth
was one of my favorite players but I
also liked Oakland and I always select
the Chiefs and they AFL the new league
at that time was explosive and it was
exciting and Sid Gillman and throwing
the ball and all those things were great
how many yards did you rush for your
senior year in high school high school
yeah I don't remember I was a
quarterback so I didn't really sort of I
was more interested in my throwing so
how was your arm barn was pretty good I
mean I wasn't very accurate
I was actually more accurate in the
prose and I was a how many times did you
throw in the NFL
six Wow pretty impressive I was 12 for
27 I was really except because that I
had quite a few drops of course you're
doing my quarterback rating I think I'm
not quite sure but it's 106 what do you
think yeah I think it is so I'm pretty
proud of that
how many schools could you have gone to
play quarterback I I don't think I was
really made a distinction of playing a
quarterback I was really a defensive
player that's what I really wanted to do
and I don't know if you know the story
Dan what happened was in high school I
was I wanted to be Jack Tatum I wanted
to hit people and the coach wanted me to
play quarterback we didn't have one and
he says Marcus you to vet athlete on the
team and we need you to play quarterback
and I didn't want to play but I went
under center anyway and I took the snaps
I took eight of them and fumbled every
single one of them on purpose and he
kicked me off the team now I was the
best player in San Diego I said this
guy's crazy my dad is gonna be irate
he's gonna be right yeah and so my dad
shot me when I got home and told him he
says well that's between you two and so
he didn't rescue me which was one of the
greatest things that ever happened and
so I had to go back and and apologize
and I said can I come back on the team
coach and say yes so I played
quarterback and as a resort of playing
quarterback and running the ball I was
recruited by a SC as a defensive back
and to my great fortune all the running
backs behind Charlie White were hurt
they didn't have anybody so they asked
me to come over to play and that's how
it happened
and so you were a fullback for a couple
of years oh just one year I laughter my
the sophomore year and then I got the
chance to play and I John Robinson one
of my favorite coaches of all time
because he changed my life
he really did how much doubt did you
have being a running but like being able
to do that well I had some doubt going
in because I really never played it I
never played the position I played it I
shouldn't say never but I played it once
in hot water when I was 11 and other
other than
and I played it was on defense and so
there was a little bit of doubt but I
thought because normally we'll take an
offensive player and you can make him a
defensive player you know you're you're
you could be a defensive back if you
were a wide receiver you know I was I
was a good athlete though any night so I
was you know it was it was going to just
take some some knowledge and a little
bull in a little time a little bit of a
little bit of effort on my part a lot of
work and stuff but I thought you know I
can make the transition pretty well what
is that feeling like when you get the
ball and that hole opens well I try to
explain it to people if you ever get it
running back and you ask him what were
you thinking on that play and he
actually gives you an answer other than
I don't know he's full of it because the
reality is you just do it it's just
instinctive and the true answer is I
don't know and you should just get out
your own way because that's what happens
it just reacts you just react to what's
in front of you and you just do these
things instinctively and I can go you
know we will go back on Monday to review
the films and guys would say how did you
do that and I would say I don't know and
I would squeeze through holes that were
like this big and the only explanation I
have is that I was born the year of the
rat but then that explains your run
against the Redskins that was Super Bowl
that it right you can't explain you
can't explain it you can't explain it
because I had the best night's sleep I
could ever have I came to the stadium
guys and I didn't know any better it's
my first Super Bowl so most guys you
know they take the cab or they jump on a
bus I took my rent-a-car we had rental
cars right and so I pulled up to the
stadium and I said excuse me where did
the players park and and the attendant
said uh the parking past and I said no
so well you can't get in
I said mister seriously I'm playing with
the Raider
planning in today's game
beautiful no she says I said I don't
care if you don't have a parking pass
you can't get in and I was with my
teammate Otis McKinney I backed the car
up pulled her against the curb this is a
true story and I looked at him he looked
at me he grabbed his bag I grabbed mine
we took off running to the lawn and to
this day I don't know what happened to
their rented car it is the true story
and he had a pretty good ganna had a
great game and but and I fumbled the
ball the first play of the game and the
ball rolled away in front of me in slow
motion
and I even so like the Rozelle one and I
just looked at all the goo in my I think
was Frank Hawkins jumped on it and I
looked at it was no big deal and I just
was like floating that that the entire
game and then on the third quarter it
was like you know you know you hear it
was the John Vicente I think it is Along
Came Marcus Allen running in the netting
it alone with you yeah Marcus and it was
just and it was just time travel can you
stay for another segment yeah okay mark
is joining us on behalf of Kay Jewelers
we'll talk about that coming up we'll
continue with Marcus Allen right after
this in the Dan Patrick show
Marcus Allen stand with us here on
behalf of Kay Jewelers in celebration of
the 18 year partnership with st. Jude's
Children's Hospital
Marcus is asking everyone to post a
video singing the famous jingle every
kiss begins with Kay every kiss begins
with Kay that was my next question
Fritzi thanks Richie you want to see if
you can pause here let me every kiss
begins with no no no listen we're doing
it for the kids sing for st. Jude
donation to trigger a $100 donation to
st. Jude's up to 15 thousand thousand
dollars got a lovely voice Marcus well
thank you so much guys and all you
viewers out there can you say I just
want you to know that I have right of
first refusal if you guys sound great
you know I'm a sign you and start a
record label though all right listen
can I sing of course I can sing like
what like what's your go-to if we go I
don't know you know
Motown stuff like what I don't know you
want to sing evany and ivory ebony and
ivory ivory part of this what's the
expression sing like nobody's listening
do you get rid them on did you ever just
wait wait no I didn't never so no no and
I maybe that's why I didn't know there
was okay okay that's that's fair they
like Barry Sanders know the way how many
rare the way I ran though you don't
think that's rhythm but Barry Sanders
didn't have any rhythm he told me didn't
ever hit no but he ran like a rhythm
yeah he was poets here in motion that's
for sure Barry was one of my favorite
running backs of all time
what you know the runningback class now
these guys you know the magicians my
favorite is the live young and and and
for multitude of reasons because he's
great but he's also tall and because we
put ourselves in a different category
guys because we always say it's easy to
be a short running back any of those
guys hide behind the line of scrimmage
there's less body to hit if you're tall
you're six three I mean I was looking
eye to eye to defensive lineman and just
think of Livia nor Dickerson or Chuck
Muncie was six four I mean you can't
hide there's a lot more body hit so we
felt like you had to be you know better
and more versatile and quicker feet and
all those different things so I mean
that's just amongst ourselves we do that
we put ourselves in a different category
but Dickerson ran in a way that nobody
has ever run unlike nobody runs like
they he runs like Michael Johnson ran
the two hundred years you're absolutely
right
he almost started low and then he would
you know obviously when they hit that
hole and then it was an opening he's
just kind of like heroes yeah and it was
it was beautiful to watch best running
back he ever saw me I like Barry I mean
yeah I mean I like all of them there's
you know I love the a ton of guys very
goes my own figure out like how is that
guy good did you ever have one of those
where I go I I don't know how because we
see this guys you know sometimes you'll
see somebody play basketball you go I
don't know he's doing it but he does it
never had that no no no I mean I would
buy a ticket to watch a lot of guys play
but I'd really buy several tickets to
watch Barry Sanders what I mean he was
the one guy that made you know and when
you do things yourself you go like you
know it's not a big deal but he was the
one guy that would make everybody go wow
that was great
and he did it with not a lot of help you
know I said Barry probably ran behind
the line of scrimmage
for more yards than anybody in the
history of the game so if you include
that and what's beyond the line of
scrimmage that meanies
you know it's an incredible job we don't
always look at this at other positions
we do at the quarterbacking position
of your legacy attached to the Super
Bowl yeah but you had an iconic run in
the Super Bowl and you won a Super Bowl
beating the Redskins but the importance
of that to your Hall of Fame career is
what well I mean it's like you said it
is a part of it
and for me personally I just I really
enjoyed this time of year because you're
always a part of the landscape and you
everybody wants to go to the Super Bowl
but to be fortunate enough to have the
game that you want to have on a you know
on that particular day is it's just it's
amazing but we don't hold other
positions accountable for not winning a
Super Bowl the way we do quarterbacks
well I always believe the quarterbacks
get a lot of credit to much better yeah
you know they they just they certainly
deserve credit but then they get too
much when things don't go well I mean we
look at Tom and for example and and
everybody talks about you know the
debate about who's the greatest
quarterback in the world they both I
mean I love Joe and I love Tom and I
think both of the great so I'm not even
good in that argument but can you fault
Tom for the two losses that they were in
I mean if David Tyree doesn't make that
incredible catch you know like that I
mean they win again
and if they you know there was a past
that was incomplete that a player should
have caught if he makes that catch the
game's over so he's you know what six
three six you know so but you know thick
between did Joe or Tom I picked Joe
because I played with Joe and I know how
but but you know San Diego no he's from
Northern California
I think it's from northern well that's
right he was a Niner fence yeah okay but
he guys I was in the huddle with Joe and
and I played with him at the sunset of
his career and he was awesome so I can
only imagine how great he was when he
was young
yeah and the best thing about him and
and and I was asked his question about
the kid from from USC Sam Arnold don't I
still forget about his his
his athletic skills and his ability his
demeanor is just amazing the entire game
I watched him on the sidelines guys he
never changed they they scored 28
unanswered points to the Penn State game
yes and he just stayed the same his
expression didn't say nothing was a big
deal and Joe was the same way no matter
what the situation was no matter how far
we were behind we knew we were gonna
come back and win because I looked at
him and he never blinked yeah we have an
i-team report on Marcus's career is that
right Paul yeah I just got a call from
Budget rental car Marcus Allen owes 96
thousand dollars that he parked a rental
car there yeah and you still don't know
what happened to that rental car that's
a true story
yeah you know I thought about that too
but I didn't I figured somebody would
just pick it up you know but thank God
it was pre 9/11 and that's the
commercials they would have shut down
the entire game and you know they would
occlude out the parking lot in the whole
nine yards my thanks to what Kay
Jewelers do you want to give us the
pitch again and maybe give us a little
singing there the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]